it's not just their racial stuff that is
actually harming minorities and poor
people
it's their economic stuff i mean this
may be the worst of all of it here is
chief economist diane swonk
on what these people are doing and why
they're doing it the worst mistake would
be to allow a repeat of the 1960s and
70s where we let inflation erode living
standards and
squeeze profit margins last combined
compound a vicious cycle that went on
for years that's worse than recession
it's nothing is good this is between a
rock and a hard place and there's no way
to extract ourselves without there being
some pain
ah i see so you buffoons who printed all
the money and caused all the inflation
and then threw all the money to ukraine
and then caused our supply chain to bust
and then locked everybody down so you
created all the unemployment
there's really nobody to blame here and
we got to have some of this pain this
pain was inevitable no it was not
because again when orange man was
president the economy was absolutely
booming but what she's basically saying
there is all of these policies that
we've put in they're going to hurt poor
and minority communities the most and
it's not just their economic policies
that do that and you guys all know that
what else what else did the left do
there was something else
in that place that we used to live guys
you remember that that horrible place
that we all used to live that that
devilish evil horrible place in los
angeles oh god puts money in the jar uh
they were defunding the police in los
angeles as of course they've been doing
in many
blue cities and in blue states across
the country and
cackling kamala harris she was very
excited about the defunding of the
police in los angeles which of course
hurts minorities the most
so does that mean you support proposals
like what we've seen in los angeles
mayor eric garcetti saying take some of
the money from policing about 150
million dollars invest it in health
initiatives training initiatives for
youth
i support investing in communities so
that they become more healthy and
therefore more safe
right now what we're seeing in america
is many cities spend over one-third of
their entire city budget on policing but
meanwhile we've been defunding public
schools for years in america we've got
to re-examine what we're doing with
american taxpayer dollars and ask the
question are we getting the right return
on our investment are we actually
creating healthy and safe communities
and that's a legitimate conversation and
it requires a
really critical evaluation i applaud
eric garcetti for doing what he's done
all right so there you have it that was
when they were running for president she
was still a senator at the time and what
did she want she was applauding eric
garcetti for defunding the police and
then the police got defunded in los
angeles just like they got defunded in
portland and seattle and san francisco
and all over the place and then crime
went through the roof murder went up
everywhere murder not good
not good there's some commandment
somewhere in some old thing that says
something about not committing murder
murder went went crazy crime petty theft
all of the bad stuff went up rape
the whole thing it all went up uh 81 by
the way this is a staggering number that
we found from quinnipiac polls and they
do they do an actual good job of polling
81 percent of black americans do not
want police defunded this was a democrat
policy much like the economic policies
and some of the other stuff that i've
been talking about that has harmed
minority communities